and we begin with breaking news in
Afghanistan where US forces say two
Americans were killed during a military
operation early today the service
members are the latest casualties of the
longest war in American history
17 years five months and 15 days a long
time these deaths bring the total number
of US service members killed in
Afghanistan this year to 413 Americans
died there last year about 12,000
American troops are still stationed in
Afghanistan amid drawdown orders from
President Trump senior foreign affairs
correspondent and Face the Nation
moderator that's Margaret Brennan is
Washington with more on this story
market start with this what is the
current state of talks between the u.s.
and the Taliban at this time welcome
morning Gail well the Afghan government
and the Taliban aren't even talking to
each other so that gives you a sense of
the tension the US envoy who's trying to
broker a deal his name is Salma Khalil
Asaad
said the US did reach draft agreement
with the Taliban about the timeline for
u.s. withdrawal but last week the Afghan
government made an explosive allegation
that the details are being deliberately
withheld from them that sparked a
condemnation from the White House but it
apparently worked because a top Afghan
official tells me this morning they are
now being briefed their fear underlying
all of this is that the u.s. is going to
cut and run and leave them vulnerable